now we are getting reports of um a car
ramming incident in the Israeli city of
Tel Aviv
we are hearing that at least 10 people
have been hurt in this car ramming and
that there was also a stabbing involved
this is what we know so far about this
incident in Tel Aviv we are trying to
find out more and I believe that we do
have our correspondent Imran Khan he is
joining us from West Jerusalem Imran
what more are you hearing about this
well the attack took place in the last
hour in central Tel Aviv a car uh
suspected to have rammed into the side
of a road uh injuring at least 10 people
we're hearing from medical sources that
that may well be five people at least
two of those we also hearing might be in
critical condition uh we're also hearing
that there may well have been a shooting
as well as the car ramming attack that
happened now
um the Israeli media is telling us that
the the suspect of the car was actually
neutralized that's a the legal well the
definition of shot dead is effectively
what that means so this is all happening
right now it's happening in Tel Aviv
there are some pictures of the aftermath
of the scene and you can see ambulance
is on the scene and you can see uh that
the kind of damage that took place but
yes this has happened in the last
like literally last 30 minutes right
Imran and uh we don't know who was
involved who carried out the attack but
we do know about what's going on in
Janine and the Israeli government was
saying when they began this very large
scale operation engineering that they
were prepared for a reaction to what's
happening in Janine in other parts well
they said they were prepared for a
reaction from other occupied territories
not necessarily Tel Aviv again we don't
know who's carried out this car ramming
but this is happening in the context of
violence taking place in other parts in
in occupied territories rather
well almost as soon as the operation
began the Israelis moved a rocket
defense system to the borders with Gaza
in order to prepare for any rockets that
may well have been fired or may well be
still fired from Gaza in occupied East
Jerusalem there were clashes that took
place between uh Utah and the Israeli
police that took place last night we're
expecting maybe some more of that kind
of thing but it's very difficult to
predict things like this these are
people who just take
operations into our own hands now for
example after the last Union attack we
saw settler violence against
Palestinians where cars will burnt
houses were attacked and Palestinians
were beaten up on the streets by Israeli
settlers who live in the illegal
settlements in the occupied West Bank so
things like this are very difficult to
predict whether as Palestinian whether
it's settler violence they're very
difficult to predict it's very difficult
to defend yourself against somebody who
simply drives a car into a busy Street
Imran thank you very much for that that
is Imran Khan with what we know so far
about this incident of the car ramming
in Tel Aviv joining us live from West
Jerusalem thank you Imran